gaby está comprando regalos en línea el
costo del envío se basa en la cantidad
de dinero de la orden para órdenes
mayores a 20 dólares el costo del envío
es de 4 dólares para órdenes de 20 o más
el envío cuesta 7 dólares podemos
expresar la cantidad de dinero de la
orden como una función del costo del
envío nos están pidiendo expresar la
cantidad
la cantidad de la orden de la orden como
una función del costo costo del envío
y me preguntan si esto se puede expresar
como una función para que esto sea una
función por cada costo de envío
deberemos tener un solo valor en la
cantidad de la orden esta es mi entrada
entrada
así que si tenemos nuestro costo de
envío
y entrar a nuestra cajita que todavía no
sabemos si va a ser una función o no
deberá tener como resultado un solo
valor en la cantidad
cantidad de la orden cantidad d
orden veamos las posibilidades bueno
solo hay dos posibilidades en el costo
del envío cuatro dólares o de siete
dólares qué pasa si yo ingreso cuatro
dólares en esta cajita en mi cajita de
relación cuál será la salida cuál será
la cantidad de la orden pues puede ser
cualquier cosa por debajo de 20 dólares
puede ser un dólar puede ser un dólar
con 50 puede ser 7 dólares o incluso
puede ser 19 con 99 todos estos valores
y muchos más pueden estar asociados a
este costo de envío lo mismo sucederá si
ponemos 7 en la entrada podré tener una
cantidad de la orden que puede ser desde
20 dólares
que es el límite inferior
hasta 100 dólares no lo sé incluso puedo
tener un millón cualquier cantidad por
encima o igual a 20 por lo que no
podemos representar esto como una
función no es función función